legend has it that somewhere beyond
Neptune and Pluto there's a ninth planet
with a mass that's five times greater
than Earth's planet 9 also known by its
more ominous name of Florida is shrouded
in mystery but what if we were able to
close this case of once and for all and
figure out if Planet 9 is the real deal
how did it get there in the first place
and how did we finally crack this
planetary puzzle this is what if and
here's what would happen if planet 9
exists let's flash back to 1846 when we
discovered Neptune after this glorious
find scientists started wondering if
there was another planet close by
astronomer Percival Lowell then used
calculations to predict a possible orbit
and location of this planet in 1930 we
thought we had finally found it but it
was another planet called Pluto you may
have heard of it so what exactly is
supposed to be out there planet 9 is a
hypothetical planet on the outskirts of
our solar system the problem is that
it's located so far away we might as
well talk about where the solar system
Amonson what's out there which is
another can of worms one theory is that
Planet 9 formed at the same time as the
other gas giants in our solar system
Jupiter Saturn Uranus and Neptune and
while little baby planet 9 was feeding
and growing basically attracting gas
from the gas disc in the solar system it
got too close to Jupiter's gravity
bounced out of the solar system because
of this planet 9 could no longer absorb
the gas it needed to continue growing
and ended up at a size of about 5 to 15
times the mass of Earth another theory
is that while the Sun was still growing
inside its stellar nursery it might have
captured an object from another star
system residing within that nursery so
in a sense Planet 9 was kidnapped from
another star system either way there's
still a lot of speculation about how it
got there and even if it's out there at
all
so how would we take it a closer look
well the thing about Planet 9 is that
it's all about the facts for us to
change our view of our very own neck of
the woods the solar system we'd have to
have hard evidence the first way and the
luckiest would just be to stumble across
planet 9 ah there it is case closed
but if it isn't that easy we'd have to
embrace our inner sleuths and track it
we could potentially catch its trail by
using T n O's or trans-neptunian objects
they're the frozen rocky bodies floating
around in the Kuiper belt we recently
found one dubbed far out and to date
it's the most distant object in the
solar system we've discovered it's
located about 123 astronomical units
away the goal is to identify as many T n
O's as possible as this will increase
the chances of discovering Planet 9 sort
of like following a trail of breadcrumbs
leading us to this enigmatic planet the
behavior of these T n O's suggests that
there is a massive object out there on
the outskirts of the solar system and
it's forcing these objects to assimilate
could it be Planet 9
well here's the thing sooner or later we
will find it if it exists many studies
are already underway and more will start
within the next few years
astronomical sleuths will use everything
from bigger and better telescopes to
faster and more powerful computers to
sift through all that data we're
discovering new cosmic objects all the
time so we may just find planet 9 after
all this isn't the first time we've
looked for something that some people
didn't think would exist there may even
be some undiscovered mysteries on our
own planet
what if deep below the ocean the Kraken
was real well that's a story for another
what if
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]